Mykleby are an author of six days of war
June 1967 and the making of the modern
Middle East why do we want to go back
and look at that six-day war in 67 well
six-day war was in many ways the the
pivotal seminal event for the creation
of the modern Middle East the Middle
East that we are witnessing today
the Middle East that is the source of so
much tension and controversy and
bloodshed
the obvious reason we want to go back is
just find out how the West Bank Gaza
Jerusalem principally but also the Golan
Heights came into the possession of the
State of Israel that happened in June
1967 but the war was also a pivotal
event for many other and even more
profound reasons for example the six-day
war really spelled the death knell for
the movement of Arab nationalism which
was a secular movement in its in its
most sublime form which was Nasser ISM
under Gamal Abdel Nasser the president
of Egypt the that movement was diligent
mised was debunked in 1967 and it opened
the door to the entry of a new ideology
into the Middle East and that was an
Islamic ideology and that has had
profound ramifications for everybody
both in the Middle East and here in the
United States as well the six-day war
also ended the period when the
arab-israeli conflict was principally a
state-to-state conflict a conflict
between Israel and Jordan Israel in
cereal Syria Israel and Egypt and this
to convict a new conflict emerge to
conflict that was principally one
between Israel and the Palestinians
before 6-7 you really didn't hear about
the Palestinians it's not by accident
that a year after the war ended in 1968
the PLO under Yasser Arafat emerges as
this powerful force in the Arab world
and we've been living with that as well
67 war was also also inaugurated the
strategic relationship between the
United States and Israel people forget
that Israel fought the 67 war not with
American arms but with French weaponry
France was is was principal ally before
that before 97 only one Israeli Prime
Minister one time for one hour had
visited the White House
and it wasn't his real founder David
ben-gurion it was it was there was levy
Eshcol one time june 1964 today Ariel
Sharon or any Israeli Prime Minister
comes to Washington it's obvious that
he's going to march right into the White
House that began that very very close
relationship that cooperation began in
the aftermath of 1967 not before that as
you acknowledge one more book on the
six-day war there'd been a lot of them
now what do you have new what kind of
things look at my photography you'll see
about three four hundred books on the 67
war and I always I always encounter that
question you know why we need another
book on the 67 war well the principal
reason is the-- is the phenomena of the
30-year rule I ride the 30-year rule
that is the rule that obtains in most
western-style democracies in the United
States in Britain in Canada and in
Israel which holds that after 30 years
the majority of diplomatic documents
that were previously classified as top
secret get Declassified and they are
become accessible to researchers and
once you have documents it opens up an
entirely new Vista into the
decision-making process and that's what
this book really is about it's about
decision making in addition in in the
last say 12 years Soviet documents
documents of the former Soviet Union
have become available to researchers and
the Soviets played a pivotal role in the
67 war very crucial role in many ways
they precipitated the crisis and I
wasn't to go to Moscow and to access
some of these documents there's also
been a new opening in at least two of
the three major Arab participants in the
war in Jordan and in Egypt there's a
tremendous wave of publications about
the war memoirs studies even the release
of certain documents which is very rare
in the Arab world about 1967 the only
place that hasn't occurred is in Syria
in Syria officially the war never
occurred there's not one single official
book at all books in Syria are official
about the 67 war how the average Syria
believes that Israel came into
possession of the Golan Heights that
formerly belonged to Syria is a mystery
to me let me go through your bio for a
moment you were born where I was born in
the tiny town in upstate New York that
was raised in
Jersey when did you first go to Israel I
first went when I was 15 years old I
went to work on a kibbutz on a farm I
worked in alfalfa I worked in the cows I
became a cowboy I was a lousy farmer so
I went and studied history what kind of
a Jew was your family your father your
mother my parents were I grew up in a
conservative Jewish community my parents
were very scientists very pro-israel
we're supportive of the State of Israel
s support of my actually moving there as
much as a shock to them they both from
here both from here yes my father had
been as it had been a career army
officer for a period in the US Army had
served in World War two in Korea and and
later on became a hospital minister so
he stayed conservatives that like the
Orthodox conservative reform right to be
right middle in track right in the
middle right and so did you fight in the
67 war no I was a kid you're a kid could
you fight any war and I spot in a couple
of them s well I fought in Lebanon War I
was quite involved in Lebanon War I
served in the Israeli paratroopers at
that point I was in Israeli Special
Forces what UN this is a 1982 in June
1982 if some reason wars in the Middle
East occur in June all most of the day
is probably good war fighting weather
and I was among the first forces to of
Israeli forces to enter the city of
Beirut in June 1982 and my actual
national unit was decimated in an ambush
and we ended up being attached to all
sorts of other units for the duration of
the war later on I became one of the few
Israelis to be a veteran of the Gulf War
in a period just before the outbreak of
the Gulf War I was assigned as a
strategic liaison between the Israeli
army and the u.s. Sixth Fleet in the
eastern Mediterranean
that's one it's an interesting thing as
an historian as well because in the book
I point out that Israel had repeatedly
requested in 1967 precisely such a
liaison with a sixth fleet and the u.s.
denied the request well in subsequent
years United States acceded to the
request and I was the liaison and it was
first it was it was a very interesting
job by essentially
went out and partied a lot with American
pilots who are on leave in Israel we had
a few maneuvers on the ground nothing
too serious and all of a sudden it
became real all of a sudden there was a
real war in which the United States and
Israel had to collaborate strategically
and you may recall that the United
States provided Israel with Patriot
missiles as an answer at least a
psychological answer because physically
they actually didn't work a
psychological answer to the Scud attacks
forty-one Scud missiles that fell on Tel
Aviv and its environs and I was part of
the team that brought in the Patriot
missiles and they were in Israel the
pair in Israel and now go back to the
Year education then where did you go to
college I did my undergrad I did a BA MA
and in all in Middle Eastern history at
Columbia Columbia College and then I
went on to do an MA and a PhD again in
Middle Eastern history at Princeton you
are you both in Israeli and American Sun
I am and why did you end up in the 82
war in Lebanon how did that work well I
I'd I'd always wanted to move to Israel
I saw my future in Israel I wanted to
raise my family in Israel and in 1973 at
the end of the 73 war which I would have
missed had I actually been living in
Israel I determined that I wasn't going
to move just then I was gonna do my my
BA first I did my BA and it turns out an
MA I ended up working for the Israeli
foreign ministry as an advisor to
Israel's mission to the UN during a very
tumultuous period was the period of the
Zionism is racism revolt Arafat speech
before the General Assembly a very very
tumultuous period and then I moved to
Israel and I tried out for this unit in
the army the Triads are rather rigorous
and did 17 months of basic training and
and got out just prior to the Lebanon
War but in Israel we have you serve for
a long period your regular service and
then you do reserve service to the age
of 52 now I have a son in the Army who
is 19 and in in a very elite unit and I
am still doing reserve duty we actually
share uniforms very bizarre how old are
you no I'm 47 and so you can be called
up at any time I have been yes I've
served I've served in the in the latest
Intifada you know
that role where I in nablus full combat
uniform well problems mostly obviously
semi-retired I now you stop jumping in
the Israeli army and paratroopers at age
37 and you you essentially ceased being
a combat soldier at age 42 at age 42 43
I was asked to stay on as an advisor on
media relations so why not sounds
interesting get good briefings but when
the fighting broke out in the West Bank
they asked any of these media advisors
if they had combat experience and like a
total fool I said of course I have one
and well we need someone to be attached
to the frontline brigade commander who
doesn't speak French doesn't speak
English and CNN and French television is
running around there someone has to
interpret for him so I was quickly
outfitted with a new ceramic flak jacket
and a helmet and a m16 the whole works
and and flown out there on a Black Hawk
helicopter which had to do a big sort of
detour around Ramallah cuz the the IDF
the Israeli army was convinced that the
Palestinians had shoulder-fired ground
to air missiles and when we landed we
landed in a hail of gunfire I've never
seen anything like it since Lebanon it
was it was intense and the brigade
commander as I landed got shot in the
head
got a 7.62 Kalashnikov bullet right in
the head that was stopped by his newly
issued American Kevlar helmet as really
haven't had the new Kevlar helmets he
just got one and there was the boat
stuck right in the helmet and I quickly
got myself a Kevlar helmet very slightly
is it ever feel so really I mean you're
one day you're at your desk at home
doing all your work away where do you
live I live in Jerusalem but and the
next day you're in a uniform and they're
always through the worst part is coming
home the worst but it always takes a few
days to make that switch you it's
bizarre you get a phone call you know
this week I'm celebrating my 20th
wedding anniversary congratulations and
I got married on August 5th 1982 as I
came home from my wedding and I was
unwrapping my gifts I got a call from
the Army
saying listen in three hours we're gonna
pick you up in a Jeep outside your house
in Jerusalem and we're gonna take you to
Beirut and I said what am I just got
married
they said well that's not our problem
three hours and I had to Donna uniform
get out of my wedding suit
into a uniform my new wife is crying my
parents who were there from New Jersey
who hadn't seen me in uniform ever were
in a state of shock and lo and behold
the Jeep comes by and picks me up and
making that transition is difficult
enough but coming back from it is even
more difficult because you come back
from combat and everyone's basically
going about their business and and
buying shoes and getting on buses and
and it's very bizarre the last two years
however have been in a category all by
themselves Israel lives from crisis to
crisis and this I think were rather
addicted to them and but this is the
last two years have broken the Israeli
paradigm this really paradigm is there's
a war it breaks out on the Golan Heights
it breaks out in the Sinai you get into
uniform you go away you come back in two
or three weeks you take a shower you try
to forget about it you go back to your
teen over the last two years however the
war has come to us and it is no longer
out there the war is in our backyards
and where I live in southern Jerusalem
it's been very very close to the to the
front I mean very typical evening with
my children around a table the house
will be rocking with gunfire with with
machine-gun fire with tank fire
helicopters have come over my house and
fired rockets and now we've had the
suicide bombings the last major suicide
bombing in in Jerusalem but the bus
bombing blew out the windows in my house
so you you live there full-time but you
also are associated with an organization
called is it the Shalom Shalom Center
celebs I'm John is a very full time job
Sun Center is a is a young very dynamic
Research Center that was started about
seven years ago through the generosity
of the the Zalman Bernstein foundation
and it
it promotes the study of Israel the
study of middle-east
Jewish history Zionism was founded by
several young people graduates of
Princeton and now they're about a
hundred people working there did I read
that bill kristol they with a standard
he's on our board publisher is on your
board any other Americans that we know
who you would know them Leon Kass is on
our board the bioethics right associated
the leader associated with President
Bush's yes Ronald Lauder your Roger
Hertog of Reliance Capital okay go back
to in the early part but you say you
wanted to write an unbiased right view
of the 67 war after hearing your
background is that possible to do that
mmm not easy not easy today in history
it's very fashionable in post modernist
relativists history to say you can't
write objective history don't even
bother trying so write subjective
history and I I adhere to that very
quaint 19th century notion that there is
an historical truth out there and that
we as historians though we can never
really reach that truth completely we
have an obligation to strive toward it
and therefore if we have prejudices and
of course we all have them if we have
biases that we have to regard them not
as opinions to be indulged but as
obstacles to be overcome because if we
want to understand this war all right
and this is the word that as I said
before so profoundly impacts our lives
in Israel in the Middle East even in the
United States
if we're gonna understand it but then
indulging my opinions are not going to
help us very much and on a sort of daily
methodological level in writing every
page every paragraph isn't that even
every sentence I'd have to stop and ask
myself okay am i letting my prejudices
ideas opinions impinge on what I'm
writing here how might I write this if I
was completely objective and re often I
change the text very often if changes
tack
the best compliments I've had from this
book Brian have come from Arab scholars
and and the reaction from the Arab world
has been overwhelmingly positive my five
have really had no negative reactions
that I've been written about in the
Egyptian press I've been asked to
interview on Al Jazeera
I've given lectures at universities
where Arab scholars were present at
Oxford and and and at Harvard recently
it's been very it's been giving me a
tremendous amount of satisfaction that
reaction by the time you get to the 67
war how many wars had Israel fought in
they said the the six-day war was
Israel's third war sometimes referred to
as the third arab-israeli war 1948 94 of
Independence the 1956 war which was
Israel's the Israelis called a Sinai
campaign the Arabs called the tripartite
aggressions one of the things about
total war we even have different names
for our war the Arabs called the 1948
war the knock by the disaster this but
this was not a disaster for this Reza
this was war of independence 67 war is
called by the Israelis the six-day war
it's referred to in the United States if
they warp the Arabs take great umbrage
at that term it simply means all these
rallies beat you in six days I actually
used it once accidentally in a an
interview with the Jordanian foreign
Jordanian general he almost entered the
interview right men he was so he was so
insulted they prefer to refer they refer
to it as the setback they have a number
of euphemisms for the war but mostly
before it was the June war sort of a an
anodyne turn after the 67 war of course
we'll go back to it but how many wars
have there been since 67 well penslar
can't we even count the words
differently maybe the Israelis identify
a war of attrition which broke out along
the Suez Canal shortly after the end of
the six-day war and continued to August
1970 in the United States brokered seek
ceasefire and then there was the 1973
war and the Arabs refer to the Egyptians
particularly refer to the 67 war the war
of attrition and the 73 war is one long
war the 73 war is called known in Israel
as the Yom Kippur War
Egypt and the Arab world is either
referred to as the October war or the
Ramadan war June 1982 the Lebanon War
which in one way or another continued
until May of 2000 and the Gulf War which
wasn't exactly an arab-israeli war but
it had a certainly an arab-israeli
component to it
as I mentioned earlier and that we've
had the outbreak of two intifadas if you
can save those words in the plural
the first from 1987 to 1992 and the last
from September 2000 to the present but
how many Americans are living in Israel
and have dual citizenship you know I
don't know it's probably around 70 to 80
thousand go back to 48 for a moment they
when did the UN declare Israel to be a
country the decision of the of the UN
came in the 29th of November 1947 when
the UN General Assembly voted to create
a Jewish and an Arab state in Palestine
to partition Palestine into two States
upon this declaration the Palestinians
declared war on the Jewish half that
effort was frustrated ultimately by
Jewish defense and when the partition
resolution came into being on May 14th
1948 seven Arab armies invaded the new
Jewish state the nascent Jewish state in
an effort to prevent its emergence and
and that was all that effort was also
rebuffed what was the size of the Jewish
state after the vote in the UN and they
partitioned it off let me let me well
I'll rephrase the answer a little bit
the the Jewish state that emerged as the
State of Israel at the end of the war of
independence at the beginning of 1949
was 30 percent larger than the Jewish
state created by the UN in November of
1947 the Israeli forces has succeeded in
pushing the Arabs back now the Israelis
had conquered
no sovereign arab country territory but
that 30% would have been part of the
palestinian arab state had that state in
fact come into being as it happened the
area that was supposed to that had been
earmarked for the palestinian state was
taken up by Israel by Jordan which
annexed the West Bank the West Bank was
post been part of that Palestinian state
and by Egypt that occupied which
occupied Gaza Strip so Israel didn't
have Gaza didn't have the West Bank you
know what part of Jerusalem did they not
have they did not have the eastern part
of Jerusalem did the little city the LC
was part of the East Jerusalem and that
didn't belong belong to Jordan that
belong to Jordan Jordan annexed it by
American terms - next it illegally the
annexation of the West Bank in Jerusalem
was recognized only by two states in the
world by Britain and Pakistan now now
how long did that Israeli state stay
together until it was Jimmy and 56 what
was that war all about the thick war was
about on the Israeli side the fear that
Nasser had become a proxy of the Soviet
Union had acquired mass amounts of
Soviet arms he was the head of a Jew he
was the head of Egypt and he had been
sending Palestinian guerrillas Fedayeen
as they were called then to attack deep
within Israel and it was only a matter
of time before Nasser used this massive
Soviet weaponry you know an offensive
war of destruction and Israel sought to
launch a preemptive strike it found an
opportunity in the Suez Crisis your call
that Nasser nationalized the Suez Canal
in July 1956 Britain and France as the
principal shareholders in the Suez Canal
Company tried to negotiate through
American mediation a solution to the
suez crisis when no solution could be
found Britain and France elected to
retake the canal by force of arms and
and enlisted Israel's help in that
effort so Israel saw a an alliance of
convenience between Britain and France
and herself and launched this war when I
just shown this map here that were the
lines the diagonal lines one at the
bottom is is the Sinai and then over
here is the
Gulf of Suez just for the audience to
look around and see where Jordan is
located Jordan used to control that area
right there in the middle of Israel
which is the West Bank and then you have
Siri up to top and Lebanon 56 war lasted
how long well for the British and the
French lasted about about three days the
Israelis that continued a little bit
longer about three four days because
Israel started the the friend Angela
French invasion the Suez Canal really
occurred on the 3rd or 4th of november
1956 and Israel had launched his attack
already on the 29th of October who was
in charge then who led the country in 56
David ben-gurion was the Prime Minister
and the the chief of the Israeli army
chief of staff of Moshe Dayan and where
were people like Ariel Sharon were they
still no the involvement Eric's run was
involved in a very controversial action
who this gets complicated Brian as part
of the deal between with Britain France
and Israel Israel was to create a a
forward think at the Suez Canal by
dropping paratroopers in and around the
Mitla pass mitla passes that is the
great pass that leads from Sinai the
interior of Sinai to the Canal Zone
Britain and France would then issue an
ultimatum to both Israel and Egypt
saying that in order to protect the
canal Britain Israel and Egypt were to
remove their forces from the proximity
that canal within 24 hours it was
assumed by the planners of this rather
arcane operation that Egypt would reject
the ultimatum and that Britain and
France would then use that as a pretext
for reoccupying the canal in order to
protect it and welcome to the Middle
East
the Israeli commander of the
paratroopers the founder of the Chimera
troopers who parachuted into the Mitla
pass was none other than Ariel Sharon
and to this day there is a controversy
or whether sharone moved his troops when
exceeded his orders by moving them into
the mid Laplace and engaging a far
superior Egyptian force and in the
process incurred a great number of
casualties
the greatest number of casualties in the
entire war were from the Mitla pass
operation and to this day it's a point
of controversy how would he have been
there he was a young man he was in his
early thirties some of the other
personalities involved
itzhak rob being where was he in 56
leading up to the 67th so everything was
it was a commander in the northern
visitor he wasn't involved in the war
where was Moshe Dayan Bosch then was the
chief of staff
where was Golda Meir Golda Meir was a
Labour Party functionary I believed at
that time she was the foreign minister
where was levy ESCO and who was the
final finance minister in 57 56 who are
some of the other leaders who are around
at that time yeah I'll be even Bobby
even was the we had a dual capacity as
Israel's ambassador both to the UN and
to the United States was his name really
Aubrey Solomon it was still is he's
still obvious he was born Aubrey Solomon
this is even in Cape Town South Africa
calls him Aubrey
when did he change his name Chay's
anybody moved to Israel as so many
people do most the people like Moshe
Dayan David ben-gurion Golda Meir these
weren't their original names the notion
was to hit brea sighs one's name to make
a media contact connection between the
Israeli Zionists present and the ancient
biblical past what was go to my hair's
never Golda Meir tsin David ben-gurion
was David Green and he was from wherever
isn't from the Ukraine from from Eastern
Europe where was it's ever been from
Irene was of a Sabra was a native-born
Israeli he was the first native native
bums Israeli areas to Rome where was he
from IO sharone is from Russia
originally he still speaks Russian and
Moshe Dino you know the Irish world
speaks Russian not not great Russian
because the passable Russian and moshe
dayan was from where most Rabanne was
born in a halal in it anymore chef
what about Shimon Perez jump res from
Poland still has a polish accent on his
Hebrew but that is often the butt of
humor in Israel what was his original
name Persky
that's good thing I remember these
things this is good good is really good
okay some of the we're leading up to
1967 by the way that did Israel win 56
he's a won the 56 militarily there is a
pattern always in Israeli military
diplomatic history that Israel wins Wars
militarily but cannot necessarily win
them diplomatically politically
certainly this was the case in 1948 1948
Israel won an overwhelming victory over
the Arabs and yet it didn't secure the
one thing that most victorious countries
achieve in war it didn't achieve peace
it didn't end in the state of war 1956
Israel decimated the Egyptian army
decimated the Egyptian Air Force and yet
did not achieve peace again 67 one of
the great military victories in all
history in terms of the of the amount of
material lost trip by the Arabs the men
lost the territory sacrificed by the
Arab forces it was just an overwhelming
victory did Israel achieve peace in 1967
no so but actually as you read your book
you get to day one I mean you break it
up eventually and and day one takes
right off from the first paragraph I
mean it was interesting up until then
it's a history right and then boom
you're in the middle of a war I mean it
and and you say by 7:30 close to 200
planes were aloft right so what again
what June 5th 1967 how big is the
Israeli military it's really military
about a hundred thousand hundred
twenty-five thousand man 200 aircraft
and were they mostly French aircraft no
American aircraft no no sentiment mostly
miss tears and mirages
and what about the images today I
thought I thought I saw a reference to
Patton tanks there were a small number
of Patton tanks it was the first
American Israeli arms deal they sell at
anem 48 tanks but Israel had a limited
number of them the largest m48 tank
force in the Middle East was the
Jordanian army which was almost
completely built around the m48 they had
about 240 of them who started that was
most advanced tank of the time
who started the 60 cent more hmm I think
it's important to keep in mind Brian
that this is a word that that nobody
very few people wanted and nobody
anticipated who's Prime Minister Prime
Minister's levia chagall who is the
defense minister fence ministers levius
coal as well
yep tool a few days before the war when
that motion Dianna's brought in as the
defense minister and what had he been
doing he had been in an opposition party
to the government with ben-gurion been
wearing had broken away from the Labour
Party to form his own party and had been
a very vituperative acerbic critic of
the of the of the Israeli government of
livius goal was it a coalition
government or the coalition government
but not with not with ben-gurion in it
who was the chief of staff of the
military chief of staff the military's
McRobbie there was some very Patricius
personalities in this in this government
there was the National Religious party
which today is by the way is a pretty
outspoken right-wing party then it was
an outspoken left-wing party there were
the there was the dutiful da which was
the kibbutz party that was in many ways
so far left wing it came around and was
right wing sort of labor Hawks so let's
go quickly
who ran Jordan King Hussein who ran
Syria there was a triumvirate of
what they call the doctors government
because they all had doctors and in
psychology or philosophy but it was
there was a bath astre jeem a radical
Marxist regime that had a front of a
civilian government but behind it was a
military Hunta which had we're in which
the the principal figure was Hafez
al-assad and his son now is in control
right and the King Hussein's son is now
incongruent who ran Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia was run by the Saudi family that
was King Saud did they get involved in
the 67 war at all they sent a force to
the border saying that they were going
to join the war and then they didn't
join the war who ran Arras secretly they
were telling the Americans we hoped the
Israelis get rid of Nasser Iran Iraq
Iraq was also run by a
this regime there was a president Arif
who is no more a radical the Arab robe
was divided between conservatives and
and radicals the Conservatives being the
monarchies Jordan Saudi Arabia the
Persian Gulf states and the radicals
being Egypt Syria and Iraq where was not
gee Riya Arafat Arafat was running an
organization called alpha which remains
his basic organization today living
where he was robbed burning out of
Damascus at the time and he was
conducting terrorist operations against
Israel with the specific objective the
long-term objective of creating
instability in the Middle East and
dragging the whole area into war it's
not Backson I opened this book
discussion of 67 war with with Al Fox
first terrorist operation against Israel
on New Year's Eve 1965 it was it was an
abortive operation but and then I show
how a series of these attacks led to an
escalation of tensions in the Middle
East and eventually succeeded in
plunging the region into war far beyond
the expectations of even the the Syrians
who were promoting these operations now
you mentioned Nasser earlier where was
Sadat Kedah was it was an underling of
Nasser he was the spokesman of the
National Assembly a person not highly
regarded in Egypt though he did have a
key role in the outbreak of the six-day
war on May 11th of May 12th Sadat would
had been sent on a state visit to North
Korea
remember Egypt this time as a radical
state they have a connections with North
Korea on the way down from North Korea
Nasser Sadat plays pays a courtesy call
to Moscow and there he is told by Soviet
leaders that the Soviet Union has
learned of an impending Israeli invasion
of Syria who's running the Soviet Union
sciencv is also run by a tram for it
this is a day of troika's there was put
gorni Brezhnev and Kosygin and there
were tremendous divisions between them
but in the Brezhnev camp there was an
interest in lessening tinge lessening
pressures on North Vietnam which at that
time was being bombed
by the United States by fomenting a
crisis in the Middle East
so as answer dot lands in Moscow in May
of 1967 what is the readiness of the
Israeli army at that point in the
airforce
not very ready may not have been at your
desk at the shelah no no no no Merv
deserves or haven't been called up there
was general tension in the area of
pickly with the Syrians the Syrians have
been firing on border settlements in
northern Galilee the Syrians have been
attempting to divert the Jordan River
before it reached Israel and to really
dry up the Jewish state by diverting
this River in it Israel had responded to
this project by bombing the Syrian
earthwork projects who controlled the
Sea of Galilee at that time Israel so
Israel Syrians were only 10 meters off
on one part of the Eastern Shore and it
was not uncommon for Israeli fishing
boats to be shot at or shelled there
were a number of instances there was
constant tension on the northern border
but these the estimate of Israeli
intelligence which has such a high
reputation was that war in the Middle
East would would not break out for at
least another three years and nobody
foresaw the war and it ended up bringing
out June 5th right after the may visited
our outlines of Moscow the Soviets tell
me that there's this there's this plan
by the Israelis to invade it's Syria to
capture Damascus the Syrian capital
Sadat goes back and tells this to to
Nasser Nasser sends his chief of staff
Fozzy to Damascus to see if there's any
evidence of this see this the the
Soviets had told Sadat of between 13 and
15 Israeli brigades massing on the
northern border so Fozzy lands and
Damascus border of of Israel on the
southern border of Syria and thous egos
to Damascus and very quickly asked for
chains from the Syrians that the Syrians
know nothing of this the Syrians aren't
under Arnette alert actually takes a
small plane up to look at the border
doesn't see any Israeli forces
massing there and he reports this Tudor
Nasser decides for political reasons to
ignore the advice of his chief of staff
and to act as if the Soviet warning is
true that Israel indeed intended to
invade Syria and he sends his entire
army into Sinai sends a hundred thousand
men into
thousand tanks and the sign eyes about
how far from Jerusalem you got in the
car and drove you got on drove be about
five hours and if you got to the hall
the way to the end no I'll closed up the
closest point is about two and a half
hours take it back yeah how long does it
take you to drive across the Sinai
Salina is quite like that's about four
or five hours from tip to tip so yeah
mr. Nasser sends the troops up to the
border the Sinai along the Israeli
border along the Australian horror now
the question is so nice not as
controlled by the Egyptians right but at
the end of the 1956 war as in return for
Israel's withdrawal from Sinai Sinai was
also taken by the Israelis in 56 the
United Nations put in a UN peacekeeping
force into Sinai
United Nations emergency force you Neff
how many men at that time about 15,000
and Nasser when he begins to send forces
into Sinai informs you Neff that they're
gonna have to leave how can he do that
mmm because the the egypt's rights visa
vie UNS were very ambiguous dag Hamish
all who was really the the the architect
of you Neff in 1957 early 1957 described
the arrangement as the good-faith
agreement that is essentially the you
Neff was was situated on sovereign
Egyptian territory it was there at the
discretion of Egypt that once you've
decided to oust UNIF it certainly had a
sovereign right to do that
but before it did that it was understood
that Egypt would first inform the
General Assembly that there would be a
general December discussion about
whether UNF had fulfilled its historic
mission now NASA would ignored that part
of the good-faith agreement and simply
informed the UN F that they had to leave
now the Secretary General of the UN was
butantã at the time and rather than
raising a protest to NASA's precipitous
move he immediately acquiesced and
ordered UNF to remove itself you imply
that who taught it was he a Burmese
mmm-hmm who was head of the UN or right
Secretary General
was a weak character I don't think he
was the strongest character in the world
I think that was that was that was the
understanding of the United States as
well and dog commercial been a strong
character he had been much stronger kind
of very dominant character so you have
and what kind of a let me jump off track
just a second here because there you got
some interesting personal stuff you say
for Emmy talked about a lot about Nasir
and his chief of staff that at one point
in this whole thing that they
contemplate suicide or at least um
America contemplates suicide the
relationship between armor is the de
facto head of the Egyptian army habla
Hakim honor Nasser is the president of
Egypt he is a by all by any other terms
he's a military dictator he came to
power at a military coup and he has been
the unchallenged leader of Egypt since
the Egyptian revolution in the early
nineteen fifties but Omer
begins to acquire power to get in in
late 1950s early 1960s he is he becomes
the commander of the army and the army
is the base of power for this military
regime he acquires all sorts of other
titles by the 1960s he's also the head
of the Egyptian Soccer Federation he
acquires considerable wealth and
influence and armour and en Nasser have
this extraordinarily complex and
convoluted relationship and one hand
armored poses the greatest threat to
nasa's rule he is he is NASA's most
bitter political rival on the other hand
Nasser and armor are best friends they
live next door to one another they go on
vacations together their families marry
with one another they have nicknames for
each other and they love each other so
you have this this strange mixture of
fear and and affection and it greatly
confuses Egyptian decision-making give
you just one example about the question
of U and F we talked about the UN forces
before Nasser wanted the UN s to pull
back from the border and to remain in
Sharm el-sheikh Sharm el-sheikh has an
area of a Sinai Peninsula that overlooks
the Straits of Tiran
at the entrance to the Red Sea that
those trades had been the block hated to
Israeli shipping if you
look on a map Brian you'll see that the
Red Sea leads up to the Israel's
southern port if a lot and from a lot
Israel could reach the ports of Asia and
Africa and once you close see it sealed
off those tracin straights are only
about a mile and a half wide Israel was
effectively blockaded from the sea and
that was an act of war under
international law as well it's a cause
as belly a reason for going to war
Nasser did not want the UN forces to be
moved from Sharm el-sheikh because he
knew that once they remove mashaallah
chef he as an Egyptian would not be able
to sit there and watch Israelis boats
pass by he would have to blockade those
straits again and that could cause a war
so he sent instructions to his officers
who were to meet with the heads of UNF
telling them we want you to move back
from the border but we want you to stay
in Sharm el-sheikh we also want you to
stay in Gaza omer changed the orders he
changed the orders for personal reasons
he want he acted was interested in
precipitating war with Israel so he
could regain some glory that he had lost
in the 56 war he changed the orders and
we know this for a fact now we actually
have the protocol of the meeting that
the Egyptians who came to the UN to the
UN forces in Sinai said we need you to
pull out entirely from Sharm el-sheikh
from Gaza at the same time immerse Santa
gyptian paratroopers to occupy Sharm
el-sheikh now once he did that where did
you find this information we found
information in the UN archives UN by the
archives also operate according to the
30-year rule they're in terrible
disarray they're thousands upon
thousands of documents and stacks on the
floor we're at the UN archive on 29th
Street in New York in New York City and
you sit there and you sift through these
and you eventually come up to reports
from the field I received them from
Egyptian sources from memoirs of the
officers involved from Egyptian
documents that existed in one particular
archive in Cairo the donc archive and a
very interesting source for me was I
also rely heavily on oral histories and
I really did which I did in most cases I
didn't go to Syria I'll tell you it's
the only place you didn't go yeah yeah
what Dourdan went to Egypt and what did
you go Saudi Arabia no there are no
interviews from
Arak bad no only older the three two
three three countries that were that
were in which interviews took place in
the Arab world are Syria Jordan and
Egypt and you didn't go to Syria no I
had an assistant go to Syria it's a
little problematic i I could as an
American citizen but because you're a
Jew or you get your assistant and you
also they went to Syria no but not
because I'm a Jew because I am an
Israeli any Israelis go to Syria there
happen Israelis go so you're on foreign
passports but it's a risky why risk it
and I have an excellent assistant
how many oral histories did you capture
and there's a long list there I think
there's a funny there's close to 100
mini and over what period of time in the
Soviet Union former Soviet Union over
three years on the former Soviet Union
in the United States in France over how
many years did you do three years it was
a three year project and you finished
this book when at the beginning of this
year I finished this book just around
September 11th of 2001 2001 okay okay I
want to just get some of this personal
stuff out I the time goes by so fast you
learn in here that dick start rub in who
is the chief of staff of the army hmm I
had a nervous breakdown he did get a
physical and nervous breakdown yeah did
he ever admit this eventually didn't and
when did he have this he had it about a
week into the crisis a week after
Egyptian forces enter Sinai and a week
after the Egyptians evicted Eunice but
before the June 5th well before two
weeks before attack she also learned
that Moshe Dayan Moshe Dayan had a
nervous breakdown into the 73 war III
where he did yes was very similar to
Rawlings did he admit that he basically
had it very publicly it was difficult to
not a minute and what does it look like
nervous for both of these gentlemen well
with Robbins that happened behind the
scenes nobody saw it he just simply
disappeared for 36 hours Diane had been
interviewed on TV and was semi-comatose
in 73 it was quite clear the man was
going through severe emotional stress
so I was very difficult to disguise it
the the the rumor would put out that
Robin had suffered about a nicotine
poisoning and only many years later he
just he came out and said that the
pressure on him
I think this comes out in the book that
this is just indescribable pressure on
his Rea leaders in the period leading up
to the war as they try to find a way not
to tattle war ever was struggling not to
get a war just became insufferable well
go back to master for a minute how long
did he live that's for little September
1970 he negotiated a ceasefire in the
Jordanian Civil War with the
Palestinians called Black September and
then he died but he was it was already
an old man by 97 he suffered from severe
diabetes how about I'm down there how
when did he die is he well that's an
issue in Egypt to this day they didn't
try to commit suicide I the official
version is that he tried to keep that he
committed suicide in August of 1967
after he tried to F try to launch an
abortive coup against Nasser anti
naturist forces in Egypt but today will
tear that armor was assassinated amber
was executed by Nasser and it remains a
point of contention within his winded
Egyptian society we need to close the
loop on Sadat's meeting in in the Soviet
Union when he went to meet with the
Soviets they told him that the trips
were on the border did he come back did
not come back and tell what do you tell
Nasser he told him just what the Soviets
said that and then we have to it's
obvious expect Egypt to come to Syria's
age what was Nasser's relationship than
the United States
very very chance poor as bad as it can
be Nasser had had come to blows almost
with President Johnson Nasser attacked
Johnson repeatedly orally in his
speeches to the point that that Johnson
suspended shipments of us week to Egypt
and a large portion of the Egyptian
population was sustained by US wheat
shipments Johnson cut it out how much
money at that time was the u.s. giving
Israel or giving Egypt Israel several
million nothing there was no
the most very little aid mostly loans
it's not the three billion everything
like it is now that started much much
later so there's so much here you can't
even begin to get to I need to get from
you though the first day of this war
what happened
June 5th what happened and what was the
extent of the you know the the deaths
and the and the destruction what's
interesting here Brian is that what we
later became the Six Day War was
conceived by the Israelis as a two day
war with very limited objectives the
Jacksons were to knock Nasser down a
couple of wrongs first of all by
eliminating his Air Force which was the
the cream of the Egyptian military
eliminating the Air Force and then by
taking conquering the first of three
defensive lines that the Egyptian army
had set up in Sinai that's all no taking
the entire Sinai Peninsula no occupying
Gaza no reaching the Suez Canal no
seizing the Golan Heights know taking
the West Bank and no entering Jerusalem
East Jerusalem all of that happened in
an unexpected unanticipated way and that
to me that's the fascinating part of the
war how how did this war snowball into
an event that has had this immense
impact on us all and each stage of that
war that was unanticipated is a story
unto itself so on the day that it
started okay when was the first
indication that people either in Israel
or in Egypt knew that this thing was
underway well the Israel Israel devised
a military plan which was ingenious and
in daring and and borderline insane
Israelis determined to send their entire
Air Force with the exception of eight
planes on a massive attack surprise
attack against the Egyptians so we're
talking about 200 planes 200 planes all
at once in the book I refer to it for
American readers and Israelis will never
understand this as a Hail Mary Hail Mary
blast right and the attack was
coordinated at a time in the morning
with different
just finished their morning patrols the
dawn patrols were coming in for coffee
they were sitting out for coffee the
plan was to destroy first of all the
runways not the planes so the Egyptian
planes could not take off essentially
they'd be bottled on the ground they I
interviewed the the former chief that
fer of a commander of the Egyptian of
the Israeli Air Force Marty Hood and
said to me that a plane in the air is
the most devastating combat tool but on
the ground is completely defenseless and
it was true they developed special bombs
called Durand dolls that penetrated the
runways with a retro rocket and blew up
huge holes some of the work run delays
too so the Egyptians could never know
when they're gonna blow up and they were
a pair and they put and so once the the
runways were destroyed all of these
Egyptian planes Soviet supply planes
MiG's torpor loves were trapped
they were sitting ducks quite literally
and then the Israeli planes mostly using
cannons and rocket fire not not bombs
destroyed these planes one after another
the Egyptians had never never bothered
to put them under canopies concrete
canopy so they were all out on the
runways completely exposed so within
about two hours Israel had destroyed
well over 300 planes so it was the
largest single military aviation victory
in military history how many planes did
each of ten about 400 ultimately lost
all but a handful and it on this day
that it starts are the Jordanians ready
to go
then what happens then there's a ground
that the Israeli ground forces also
moved to take that first line of defense
now Israel sent a letter to the
Jordanians Israel that time had a pretty
open connection with King Hussein you
know in his rhetoric Hussein could be as
anti-arab a Israel as anybody but
secretly he was meeting with Israeli
emissaries he had open communications to
the American and British embassies the
Israelis sent a warning to King Hussein
saying listen this is between Egyptians
Nos
stay out of it you stay out of it
nothing will happen but Hussein had a
terrible dilemma he was afraid if he
stayed out of it then the Arab world
would accuse him of treason and they'd
kill him so he had invited the Egyptians
to command his army he put his army
under Egyptian command and Egyptian
commanders had received word in
that the Israelis with israeli air force
had been destroyed that the egyptian air
for that gyptian ground forces we're
proceeding toward hebron and therefore
the joining forces were to enter the war
immediately so jordan opened fire on
Westar is michelle jerusalem massively
it's shelled the outskirts of Tel Aviv
Jordanian planes strafe lower Galilee
and when Israelis began to fear that the
Jordanian army was going to move into
West Jerusalem as ahead in 1948 that's
when they struck back that's when they
began to strike back in the West Bank
and Jerusalem and that's how that stage
of the world bad did they hit Jordan
when they the Israelis know hit the
joining the Jordans the Jordanians by
the way fought very valiantly in many
cases to the last man last bullet but
eventually Israeli forces overwhelmed
the Jordanians and they took the West
Bank and in a very bloody battle they
took Jerusalem what kind of planes were
the Jordanians flying training planes
had hawker hunters British planes most
of which never got off the ground what
about the Syrians were they flying MiG's
so they're flying Russian planes you
were flying the Israelis were flying
French French planes and the Egyptians
were flying Russian planes Russian way
there was one point early in the history
of all this you say the Russians were
very pro-israel and then they totally
flipped right what year did they do that
I flipped there's we have a date 1953
they flipped what was the reason for
well essentially because the read the
reason was that they that the the
initial motivation for Soviet support
for Israel was no longer relevant the
Soviets had supported the creation of
Israel way of dividing the British
Empire in half remember the British in
1940's had their forces along the Suez
Canal the Suez Canal was the largest
British base in the world the Soviet the
British were also in Jordan the British
were in the Persian Gulf a British
officer in 1919 45 could get in his Jeep
and drive from Egypt
through Iraq and still be within
Egyptians a British sphere of influence
so the easiest way to put a wedge
through the two halves of the British
Empire was to create a Jewish state
right in the middle if you look on the
map again you'll see especially the
negative desert divides
Egypt from Jordan and Mesopotamia Iraq
so they're supported and by 1953 Israel
was an accomplished fact
clearly the Soviets had more to gain
from the air
the united states become very dependent
on Arab oil and many Arab regimes were
then there was a tremendous political
upheaval in the Middle East there was
there were coos every week and many of
these coos were like the baddest in in
Syria and Iraq were pro-soviet so it
became natural for the Soviets to
support these regimes we only have a
couple minutes left and I want to make
sure we get into the end of all this in
the end there were what a half million
Arabs have had troops and all involved
in all this how many of them died but
between 1520 thousand Egyptians died
several thousand Jordanians thousands
some couple hundred Syrians the Syrians
were the least scathed in this combat
they were the what they were the
principal principal factor for
precipitating the war and they pretty
much stayed out of it too the last day
when Moshe Dayan decided to take the
Golan Heights as well how many Israelis
died between seven and eight hundred how
many planes were lost 20 percent of the
Israeli Air Force was lost in spite of
this tremendous victory Israel also paid
a very very heavy price many planes were
lost so when this war was over in six
days
why do you say again this is such an
important war and it still resonates
today well as I said earlier because the
map had changed all right first of all
you had a relationship between Israel in
the United States that didn't exist
before
and that was to play it from a central
role in Middle East politics since then
and continues to this day to play that
role Nasser was finished moreover not
just a nasty individual but the idea of
Nasser that there was going to be a
nationalist Arab movement that was gonna
reunite the Arab world that was debunked
now they were now that would have to be
a new idea and that idea that idiom was
going to be Islamic and not nationalist
the Arab regimes were sick and tired of
the arab-israeli conflict
let's give it back to the Palestinians
let the Palestinians fight their own
fight from now and that's when you have
Arafat emerging
and then you had the physical reality
was different Israel had more than
tripled its size in six days
extraordinary and Israel had the means
now to bargain for peace November 1967
few months after the end of the war the
UN passes resolution 242 which implies a
deal of territory for peace which
remains the basis for all you all Middle
East mediation to this very day
that was the document this is the
founding document and Israel was later
to get a peace treaty with eat with
Egypt by giving back the Sinai if Israel
is to ever sent have a peace treaty with
Syria it is because is real Concord the
Golan Heights in 67 and even if there's
a really is to be a peace between Israel
the Palestinians it'll be a basis of a
territorial deal that arose is years
olds roles as direct results in 67 more
you told us that you're still in the
reserves and you have a son now who is
how old it's in there 19 he is the
unactive duty very active where I don't
know he serves an elite very elite unit
and I don't know where he is
how many people in Israel under arms
right now we have actual numbers of our
standing armies there's a state secret
it's large several hundred thousand all
together with the reserves Israel could
field an army of several hundred
thousand people by the way are the
Israeli Arabs in this army there are
Israeli Arabs who serve in the army they
are dared under no obligation to serve
there's only one non Jewish population
Israel the Druze who have volunteered to
be drafted beginning 1956 but there are
great numbers of veterans Israeli Arabs
both Muslims and Christians who serve in
the army and Sirk Asians served in the
Army you still by the way you have an
American citizenship I do
we're out of time we got a lot more we
could talk about but six days of war is
the title of the book our guest has been
Michael B Oren who is both an American
and an Israeli citizen and we thank you
very much thank you for